All right, so
let's walk through the pseudocode
with a very tiny little example in mind
just to see how the value updates work.
So what we're doing here is we start
off at the beginning of an episode.
We say that the eligibility for
all of the states is 0.
Zero.
And the new values,
the new value function
is whatever the value function was
at the end of the previous episode.
So we just make a note of that.
What we're going to do for this example
is just keep track of the changes.
So this ultimately it's all going to
get added to whatever the previous
value was.
All right, so now we make a transition.
And the first transition we make is
from S1 to S2 to with reward r1.
What does that do to the eligibility?
>> Well, for
S1 it sets the eligibility to 1.
>> Good.
All right, then we're now going to loop
through all the states, all of them,
and we're going to apply the same
little update to all of them.
And the update has the form,
whatever the current learning rate is
times the reward that we
just experienced, the R1,
plus gamma times whatever
the previous iteration value was for
the state that we landed in.
Minus the previous iteration's value
of the state that we just left.
All right, so this quantity is going to
actually get added to all the states,
but the amount that it's going to
get added to all the states
is proportional to the eligibility for
that state.
And since, at the moment,
states S2 and S3 are ineligible,
they have their eligibility set to 0,
really nothing's happening there,
we're only making an update
with respect to state S1.
>> Oh, okay I see.
So then why are we bothering?
>> Well, it's not clear yet.
For now, let's just make sure
that it does the right thing.
Then we'll talk about why it's
a reasonable thing to have done.
Okay, I trust you Michael, implicitly.
>> All right, so
that's the changes that we've made so
far to the new value function for
S1, S2, and S3.
All right, now we take the next
step which is from S2 to S3.
Oh wait, no, sorry.
Before that, we have to decay
the eligibilities for everybody.
So the 0s decay to still 0, and
the 1 decays down to gamma.
Right.
Now, we've done that update from
the step that we just took, we take
the next step, S2 to S3 reward r2.
So, what does it tell us to do?
Well, the first thing is, we have to
update the eligibility of the state that
we just left, so
that bumps S2s eligibility up to 1.
Then we go through everybody and
we add this quantity again.
So what's the new quantity?
It's r2 plus gamma times
the value of the state that we
just left minus the previous value
of the state that we, no sorry,
the state we just got to and
the state we just left.
All right, so this is this update
that is now independent of
which state we're actually changing.
We're going to apply that everywhere.
But we're going to apply
proportionally to the eligibility.
So the eligibilities are at the moment
gamma 1 and 0 so gamma 1 and 0.
So we just have to add this
into the other things.
>> What does that look like?
>> So through the magic of cut and
paste,
we can actually add that same complex
quantity to both these updates here.
And in particular,
we're multiplying by the eligibility.
So for the first value,
we have this extra gamma in here.
For the second one, nothing.
And for the third one,
it gets multiplied by zero, so
I didn't even bother to write it.
So this is starting to look a little
bit hairy, but that's okay,
because we're going to
do some simplification.
>> Okay.
So here's the interesting
thing to observe.
That previously we added
in this value of S2,
according to the previous
value function, times gamma.
And now we're subtracting away the value
of S2 from the previous iteration.
And we're multiplying that by
this gamma and this alpha.
So they actually match exactly.
This thing [SOUND] and
this thing [SOUND] cancel.
>> That's beautiful.
>> So now I can rearrange
the remaining terms and
make it look a little bit simpler.
All right, and
this is the simplified form that we get.
It compactifies really
nicely actually and so
we have something that's of
a similar form that we had before.
But the point is that mainly what just
happened is we regrouped terms and
the S2 related stuff in this term,
in this update here, cancel.
So the last thing we do after we've done
all those value updates is we update
the eligibilities and
we're ready for the next step.